closer than it appears one of the
largest discovery of natural gas in the
last two
decadesanji the fossil fuel is both a
blessing and a curse it spells the end
of a lifetime catching fish in the area
but the promise but what the government
says will be a prosperous future
I want us to profit from the gas because
as soon as we start extracting I expect
the electricity prices fuel even food
prices will drop and become affordable
for us he is not alone Europeans no
longer wanting to rely on Russian gas
are looking at Africa to meet their
energy needs Germany and Poland have
signed deals with Senegal's government
Europeans will have access to Senegal's
resources before its own citizens and so
this has left many Senegalese wondering
how much will they benefit from their
own country's resource because so far
for many young men opportunity means
boarding one of these fishing vessels to
travel to Europe illegally the
government hopes that the gas project
will stop this and bring jobs here at
home at the country's new oil and gas
Institute engineers and doctorates are
given certified training for industry
jobs as the resources belong to the
Senegalese people for the Institute
director The Fallout of the Russia
Ukraine conflict on Europe's energy
problems may offer an opportunity for
African countries to change the power
dynamics technically in the leadership
position we want to be able to have
whenever it comes to decision making
this is project for selling out for the
development of the country and it's
important that we have our Senegalese
National sitting at the table
representing the government
the consequences of a conflict in Europe
away from this continent is affecting
nji's future the Senegalese Coast Guard
appears in the distance not to protect
fishermen like him but the precious new
resource destined for Europe
with the state offering him training and
welding and electricity the end of life
on the ocean appears to be on the
horizon
is joining us live from Dakar now and
you're at a energy conference there Nick
where some of the very important
conversations that you mentioned in your
report are continuing to take place
there
that's right Liz and this conference
that started 17 years ago at the time
the conversation was about who's going
to provide energy to Senegal how are
they going to power uh people's homes or
factories today the conversation
couldn't be any different people
countries from Europe are lining up
we've seen the president of Poland the
chat the chancellor of Germany the
president of France all lining up
queuing up to get a bit of that
liquefied natural gas that Senegal has
enormous resources that could put
Senegal in the top 10 producers of the
world and change the circumstances for
the Senegalese now the exportation of
that liquefied natural gas will start at
the end of 2023.
but the big question is is Senegal ready
now joining me now is Manara Sal for the
general manager of petrosine which is
the national company so is Senegal ready
to export that liquidify natural gas
on the serious note uh we are the last
child of all these countries that have
now gas and and oil so we learn from the
other guy that did not very well and we
learn also from all the best practice
all around the world so Senegal is ready
we will take the best of this and
especially and that's that's very very
important in our constitution of Senegal
it is written that the natural resource
belong to people of Senegal so no doubt
we need to take the best of it so again
we are ready we have the human resources
to handle this properly so no doubt
Senegal is very well prepared to take
advantage of our networks let me ask you
this question the Russia Ukraine crisis
how has that affected things for you
because a couple of years ago at cup 15
rich countries were asking poor
countries to go green and now we're
seeing them lining up here to get some
of that fossil fuels explain that to us
of course this is an opportunity when
when things are changing at the place
that they are changing especially with
this crisis of course people are not
coming back and saying can we have your
gas so this is a great opportunity for
us but again
how can you ask someone when you know
that this continent we have more than
600 million people that cannot have
access to electricity to power so how
can you tell us not to use our fossil
fuel so we are lucky that we have this
opportunity of people we are already
aligning up to get the part of this girl
so we are lucky that with this
investment with of course all the
partners that we have for this field and
I'm sure that people now accept that we
have to use our natural resources and so
in effect will you be able to power
people's homes here and take out 70 I
think most people in Segal do not have
access to power today well that changed
that will definitely change we have a
strategy called gas to power to replace
the fuel by gas that we are and of
course by doing that we are reducing the
cost of the of the power so no doubt
people will be getting access 100 of the
population of Senegal we get access to
electricity by 2025. my name is and
thank you very much for this interview
now the economy of Senegal is growing by
eight percent a record amount according
to the World Bank and at the end of the
year they'll be exporting this gas by
the end of 2023. it will change the
circumstances of Senegal and bring in
billions of dollars of revenue for this
country where most people don't have
access to electricity but here's the
challenge Liz at the end of the year or
at the beginning of 2024 is a
presidential elections that's going to
be hotly contested is makisal the
current president going to run for
another term or are others going to step
in whoever is the next president will
have will be in charge of a country
that's wealthier than ever before and
that's the challenge ahead for Senegal
and the Senegalese people here back to
you Liz Nick thank you for that Nicholas
Hart live for us in deca